hi everyone how good is your
communication skills this is extremely
important because good communication
allows you to have good relationships
with anyone anywhere at any place and it
opens the door to more opportunities
which then leads to a more successful
life
paul mayer said communication and human
connection is the key to personal and
career success now to help you improve
your communication skills i'm going to
give you my seven best tips these are
some of the things that i learned myself
over the years because my communication
skills were terrible
my first language is not even english
it's afrikaans but let me not waste your
time let's get right into the video
now just very quick if it's the first
time that you hear my channel my name is
daniel and welcome to dlm men's
lifestyle if you haven't subscribed yet
please consider it and then also click
that notification bell here so you won't
miss any of our future videos now let's
start with the first communication skill
[Music]
active listening now if you're one of
those guys to say and think well what
does
listening got to do with good
communication skills well that just
shows you how bad your skills really are
because it's got everything to do with
it it is one of the most important
skills that you can learn the big
mistake most people do is they just want
to hear enough for them to be able to
respond
no
active listening means really focusing
on the person to really understand what
they are trying to tell you
listening to the intention behind their
words by focusing on their facial
expressions body language and tone of
voice
peter drucker said the most important
thing in communication is to hear what
isn't being said
and that is why it is never a good idea
to look away when someone else is
talking to you because then you are not
seeing the nonverbal communication which
is a lot more communication than their
words
in a general setting 55 of communication
is body language 38 is tone of voice and
seven percent is the actual words spoken
now of course these numbers might change
depending on the situation but you get
what i'm saying you gotta improve your
active listening skills by truly putting
your attention on the other person to
fully take in what they are telling you
engaging with them rephrasing and asking
questions to make sure you understand
them look at their facial and body
expressions and you do all of this by
also avoiding distractions for example
when someone's talking to you don't look
at your phone and don't interrupt them
as well that is so rude well
unless they're one of those people who
just always keep on talking and they
will keep you there the whole day if you
don't interrupt them listen
if you truly care for other people then
you will listen to what they are trying
to tell you it's almost like an art
truly listening to what people are
saying
because it's nothing to do with ego
it's all about being humble
and all about loving other people and
improving your active listening will
build respect with other people because
they will feel that you really listen to
them that you really care about what
they have to say
if you don't do it the opposite will
happen and they will feel the opposite
clarity this is very important you need
to speak clear
some people for some reason speak very
soft they kind of mumble their words and
other people speak too loud too fast and
it's all very disturbing there's a
balance
you speak clear
you speak just loud enough so they can
hear you
and here's another thing some people for
some reason start out good they speak
good but then they turn their face away
from the person they're speaking to and
the last few words they kind of mumble
when they walk away you can't hear that
another problem is your accent if you
speak soft and with a different accent
and sometimes fast
then you can just stop right there
because that person is not going to
understand you
so all you got to do is just to be
self-aware and speak with clarity
[Music]
empathy are you able to put yourself in
someone else's shoes to kind of feel
what they are feeling to know what they
are going through
or
do you just not care because you are
selfish
you know selfish people will always have
a hard time connecting with other people
because they don't have empathy
and people can feel it john medina said
empathy works so well because it does
not require a solution it requires only
understanding
if you truly want to connect with people
to build strong lasting relationships
with them then you need to have empathy
that means truly understanding their
emotions the situation they are in and
then responding to them in the right way
so that they will feel understood so in
short just understand how people truly
feel
and then give them an appropriate
response this is something that you
cannot fake you need to truly care for
other people
honesty and kindness you know i really
don't like talking to people who are
rude who are not friendly who just don't
care and people who don't have an open
mind
most people don't like talking to people
like that and that interferes with good
communication if you are honest and kind
it builds trust
in people and it improves good
communication if you do that if you are
just a nice person that people can talk
to then of course they are going to talk
to you
they will actually want to hear what you
have to say kenneth blatchert said
honesty is telling the truth to
ourselves and others
integrity is living that truth
if you are a man with integrity then you
will also be honest and friendly with
people
and you can improve the way you
communicate with them by smiling while
someone speaks to you making small
gestures asking them how they are doing
and then praising them if they did
something good
you have to build people up
start to focus less on yourself don't
talk too much about yourself put the
focus on them talk to them build them up
and always remember this
people will forget about the things you
say but they will never forget how you
make them feel
respect
now you need to understand what true
respect really means in different
settings for example if you are in a
group of people you need to show other
people respect by giving them time to
speak
it's not good when there are a lot of
people in the group but only two are
kind of hijacking the conversation
and the other people they really don't
even get a chance to say anything sit
back and give other people chance to
speak you need to know when to initiate
communication and when to respond this
is very hard for people to do who are
very selfish you need to be unselfish
it's also very hard for people who are
extroverts
but you need to do it focus on other
people more than yourself
be more self-aware start to respect
other people everyone doesn't matter who
they are where they're from you have to
talk the same way to a president than
you talk to someone cleaning the toilets
a human being is a human being you got
to respect everyone and talk to them in
a respectful way don't talk to them
because of who they are in a different
way
talk to everyone the same because of who
you are albert einstein said i speak to
everyone the same way whether he is the
garbage man or the president of the
university this is something that you
can learn to do especially if you speak
with someone one-on-one
stay on topic answer their questions
fully and look them in the eyes when you
talk to them with a kind and humble
attitude i have heard this quote
somewhere no matter how educated
talented rich or cool you think you are
how you treat people ultimately tells
all
integrity is everything
[Music]
timing timing is crucial in good
communication some people are terrible
at it because they are so focused on
what they want to say that they are not
really
reading the room they don't read
people's nonverbal communication and
their emotions their facial expressions
and then they say the wrong things at
the wrong time they start whole new
conversations in a different direction
where nobody is actually ready for it
this is why it is so important to focus
on people's nonverbal communication
while you are speaking to them small
facial expressions and body language
will tell you when the person is born
when they are in a hurry or when they
are disagreeing with what you are saying
you got to learn to read the room the
atmosphere and a huge mistake a lot of
people do is they talk too much
there's a difference between
communication and conversation
they are different
then something else you can focus on
time your words and your sentences
better don't rumble it off take control
of every single thing you say
and then give a pause every now and then
so that the listener will have enough
time to take in whatever you are saying
[Music]
confidence always speak with confidence
even at the workplace this is very
important because people are more likely
to agree with you or when you present
something they're more likely to like
what you're doing if you present it with
confidence people won't trust or believe
in what you are saying if they feel
that you don't believe in yourself
and you can appear more confident
by doing a few things like just
preparing what you want to say
beforehand so that your speech is smooth
and then sit up straight keep eye
contact and speak with clarity and
always remember there's a huge
difference between confidence and
arrogance simon sinek said confidence is
believing in yourself arrogance is
telling others you're better than they
are
confidence inspires
arrogance destroys
now if you want more self-improvement
tips check out this playlist here and
i'll see you there and always remember
life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys